you have the people the technology you
have the product which is amazing and
challenging and the business that drives
it through
so you know it's a that's just a
successful company and you see the
people that come in and those are the
people that you know they i think that
they look at placer and they understand
the story
on our growth and they want to do the
same they want to be part of the success
which is just unbelievable
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today's
talk is about architecture but not the
type of architecture that we're used to
made avigabai the chief architect of
placer ai
avi joined placer ai in august of 2020
as chief architect in order to help
build a world-class physical market
intelligence platform which helps
businesses make data-based decisions avi
was born and raised in a moshav in the
center of israel then moved with his
family to shanghai china where he spent
his teenage years in high school avi
became fascinated by computers
programming and technology he later
returned to israel as a lone soldier and
served in 8200 as a group leader of
intelligence analysts avi is an
experienced software engineer and
architect and has worked in many
enterprises and early stage startups avi
holds an msc in computer science and a
global mba majoring in innovation and
entrepreneurship from idc hurts leah
your background is so fascinating from
being a founding member at corelogix and
then activision and director
architecture platika and variety of
other
positions
all around in between but today also
architect at placer ai one of israel's
cornerstone startups and they were all
very very proud of in the scale of
nation but
i you know i have to say that you know
besides having a common thread of them
being deep tech software companies you
know one of the things that make it
really unique is the fact that you've
been building architectural projects for
so long and not the kind that we're used
to seeing in the houses but more in
software and and that you know i really
want to start there avi what does it
mean to be an architect in your eyes
okay so
you know in my eyes and um you know an
architect um
the first thing is uh is a plumber right
and uh the end of the day you know like
you talk about buildings it's it's about
the plumbing first right and i also call
myself chief plumber even though i hold
the chief architect position and the
idea is that you really need to
understand how the piping on the system
is connected
where there are leakages
how can you replace them with minimum
collateral damage
and
how do you build right how do you add
more to that building right
so if we have a system so how do we make
it plugable so that we can really
replace parts of it while it keeps
running with minimal downtime or even no
downtime hopefully and uh and for that
you need to
to know the the real you know the stones
the building stones of your
of your company of your of your code and
your system and as i and we always say
you know in placer when me and my chief
rnd when we discuss there's really this
sort of like dolphin movement so an
architect the one hand you know stays up
high looks at everything and at some
point he needs to deep dive he deep
dives you know it takes a lot of errand
days long it deeps dive into the code
you know whether if it's taking a new
project or to replace something existing
or to solve a very specific problem
and then after a while needs to go back
up and look you know things that are
more strategic to the company and then
there's really this sort of like dolphin
movement of going in and out the water
um to push the company forward by
understanding
what is going down in the field on one
hand and you know when visiting
um what the day-to-day developers are
doing the engineers and on the other
hand you know go go up look at the
management look at the business product
and understand
how we make sure that you know our
architecture our system is able to scale
and meet our customer needs um of course
in a timely manner because time is
always of the essence but but what does
this actually mean in the day-to-day so
you come into the office what do you do
do you open the git repository and start
code review do you go to the executive
team meetings and and talk about company
strategy
how do you
balance all these things
so the day-to-day
changes as i said um it really changes
based on priority and based on the
challenges that the organization is
facing and that's what i love about my
um about my day-to-day is that today
didn't doesn't look like yesterday or
the day before
of course i'm right here today with you
so that's completely different and
special day but you know i come to the
office first of all um today i'm acting
as cheap architect so i have my team i
have an r1 architect
in my team um on one hand on the other
hand i'm running all the production
engineering they are really the arm of
the infrastructure so there's two teams
that i'm running as a manager today um
so there is you know taking care of
people making sure that missions are
getting done of course i have team leads
there but still you need to make sure
that everything is moving on the other
hand
you look at problems within the
organization we have new features coming
out we have issues with our current
features that we may need
to rewrite and this is really when we go
into design sessions or we understand
that there's some sort of an escalation
that happened whether it's because of
the customer or because we see
services keep on crashing or it might be
because of cost is skyrocketing and then
you're saying okay i need to go ahead
and figure this out so do i do it myself
is it a problem that really requires my
attention or maybe can somebody else do
it under my guidance
and this is really what my team is for
is so that they can you know sort of be
the front line and on specific problems
that might be very very tactical and
they'll need some extra help um this is
where i go in yes i go into the git
repositories i code whether if it's uh
infrastructure code and you know moving
deployment um across the board and
making them some sort of shared
libraries or whether if it's like new
products for example our placer api
which we released um about three months
ago um it was a project under my lead me
and
my architect ilya
we did it we we did a blitz over a
weekend and just you know wrote this
whole thing and
just like startups right we made a poc
and mvp got a few customers to test it
brought some more people on the team and
at a certain point you know we left the
architects leave you move it to the
day-to-day management of you know great
managers that we have in our company
that can take this product and scale it
but the building stones the ideas um
how how it is designed and how it can
scale and bring in more and more
customers um this is of course the work
of an architect uh even though i will
say that you know i believe that
everybody needs to be an architect in a
way right all the engineers need to
understand the bigger scope it's very
hard not all of them have the
capabilities yet but if we look at um in
a world you know when everything is nice
and green i would say that everybody
does architecture the design is not my
responsibility it's not my only
responsibility right i i look at the
whole system i look at strategy and make
sure how we move it into something more
tactical and operational
but all the engineers themselves of
course they need to know how to design
they need to understand the impact of
when they decide to you know to write a
specific component and what are its
limitation what is the critical chain
there and um
i do that by by leading by teaching as
well and being there to listen to them i
hope that they come to me and i think
this is part of the leadership role of
uh of an architect because it's not just
as you said opening that git repository
and being you know
um a top a top-notch engineer and tech
lead i think that an architect as well
um because he usually you know i'm
putting my chief um architect position
at the moment but previous roles
you're you're not a manager right you
don't um have that authority over people
you're a leader by example not by
authority it means that
when you want to come and talk to people
and con you need to convince them we're
all great engineers everybody has their
own religion everybody has their own um
way of thinking and they think that
their that their solution works best
however you need to convince based on so
many different factors from
product time to market and whatnot um
scalability um and you need to convince
those people that they should listen to
you and it's very difficult because you
know we're all a bit arrogant in our
sense and we always think that we are
right um and this is uh what i love
about that position is that
you know you get to talk to people you
get to convince people and show them a
different way which is
not necessarily the um the regular
leadership that we say you're not the
boss you're a leader and you need to
become a leader and in every
organization
it goes all over again the only
difference is that you come maybe with a
bit of a big a bigger record but at the
end of the day people assess you
on a day-to-day and every new you know
software engineer especially seniors and
technically that comes into our
organization into the organization
will look at you and say okay well prove
yourself so you're in a bit of um
continuous you know uh proving who you
are what are the capabilities and why
should people you know still keep on
unfollowing you and following the way
that you see this architecture and the
system move um because then they you're
really you're another manager
right and so what i'm hearing from you
is that
you know
part of this understanding of this is
leadership by example and and the
ability to
you know you're not leading by authority
you're getting credibility through
actionable you know things that you've
done and then you're working with the
team and perhaps with a little bit of
with a little bit of more background
where you're able to actually come
together and and and guide projects and
with
different thinking that than others may
have and i think this
leads me to the question you know when
you're approaching a new project
and obviously you have to balance you
know the the customers the executive
team the engineers the the current stack
of the company
what keeps you up at night so you have a
team of five great engineers that are
about to embark on this project and
you're sitting there right now in the
role of an architect and this is you
know the role that you're holding
what are you concerned with what are the
questions that you may be asking
yourself
that
based on what you just said you also may
wish others will be asking themselves as
they're about to embark on this coding
journey
so um
at the end of the day you know you look
at so many different levels right um
first of all because i don't implement
on the all the code um so it's it's
really hard to say hey and we have so
many engineers today it's not like a two
three-man show when you can code review
each other very quickly so you need to
think of where the pitfalls and many
times you know i write to myself on my
to-do's um go ahead check this piece of
code or go over with this person make
sure that there is a database connection
or that the way that we publish uh
messages through our streaming uh
processes that we do it the right way so
this is you know maybe a bit on the
lower level on the next level is saying
do we really can we scale it can we
really scale the system did
the um component we're currently writing
we know exactly where the bottlenecks we
see them very quickly but then there is
you know there is many things that we
need to to decide on if we are going to
keep going the same way with the same
technological stack that we chose or
maybe that we made a mistake because
sometimes there's not enough time to poc
so many times i go ahead and knight and
i poc myself and i take a specific piece
of code and the technology that we chose
and i try to bombard it as much as i can
to make to make sure that it makes sense
right so things that are you know more
on the scale side i do a lot of the
testing early on um and i let the team
focus more on the coding and the
day-to-day business right and i go on
the side and do some more you know
exploring and making sure that it's okay
um lastly there's a lot of things to do
with timelines so you intro it's very
easy to say let's introduce this new
technology and it works great and then
you reach
massive scale and then it breaks and do
you have the community we use a lot of
open source because we love the
community and we love giving back but
then it breaks so did we choose the
right thing and also you need to you
need to ramp up everybody right we don't
want to ramp up everybody all the time
so you have to choose on something that
has enough depth that can carry you you
know a certain amount of years forward
so that you won't have to change your
technological stack every couple of
years it's very wasteful and you see
that it happens in many startups they go
on the latest technology um it sounds
great on their resume you know they
sound very technological but they start
when they have you know five ten twenty
customers depending on the business it
works amazingly or when they have a
small amount of data and then they start
growing and growing and growing and you
say well that is not going to scale
right and you you hit so many problems
so an architect's position you know in a
cto position as well
is to go ahead and when you make those
decisions to make sure that they're wise
and you understand
how far can they carry you and meet your
business needs and the growth of your
company and working at a company like
placer where we over doubled ourselves
last year and we tripled ourselves three
years in a row where we have thousands
of customers you know we grew by over 50
times over like four years it's it's
amazing
the scale grows as well so how do you
prepare yourself usually you say 10
times but how do you prepare to grow 50
times um it's not simple
and this is really what startups are
about you start but you explode right
and you burn the money and you want to
move forward as fast as you can
but
everything that holds this business
together
has to be driven on a technology that's
um that's mature enough that
all your developers your engineers can
understand and can rely on
and not to deal with crisis every day
because your infrastructure fails and
i have to say that luckily
in placer we built an infrastructure our
new infrastructure in the urea
architecture that we're doing it doesn't
fail as much anymore so suddenly you see
a relief there's no more late night and
going crazy on the databases and seeing
how we can optimize suddenly there is a
lot of more subtleness
and
and you know and then everybody's more
happy of course but also developers are
working much better
so this also keeps me up and now at the
end of the day to understand what kind
of technologies we want to choose for to
choose and are they the right
technologies for us at the stage that
we're at you know one of the things that
i'm always fascinated by in this show
it's understanding why people make the
decisions they're making you've had such
an incredible you know journey so far
with with amazing companies that did so
well and you know i'm looking at the
point in time where you chose to join
placer and you pretty much at that point
you had the luxury of choosing you know
where you want to work and and and what
you want to be doing yet you chose
placer what came into your your own
internal process deciding that this is
the next position that you're going to
be holding for a few years
so i i have to say that okay the it's
kind of funny the way that i got
introduced to placer was uh
was
based i one of my manager was moving to
be a vp r d at
placer and no i'm the ceo called me up
for a reference
and this is how me and noah and noah
bentley our ceo got in touch and of
course as time passed by i just started
working at platika and tried to pull me
and pull me over and you know after a
while i finally got the guts of actually
making that move because it's not an
easy move you know small children two
children at home working nights
you know the day to day is hard um more
than that you know there is a lot of
challenges going on um there's also you
know there are many other aspects of the
work that are not simple
and when i
first talked to nom you know face to
face with heroes in israel
i you know it just i was i just fell in
love with the person i see a ceo
who comes from a technical background he
still understands he's very analytically
understands technology not maybe you
know the day-to-day that you know me and
my team talk but he understands a lot
and he's so transparent right there is
this amazing transparency open-minded um
and he loves to share you know his ideas
how he sees the company or see the
company grows and then he tell me come
meet with the rest of the founding
members and you know and some of our
technical leaders and this was sort of i
was interviewing them in a way they were
interviewing me was all very friendly
and you're saying wow these are the
people that i want to work with they are
they're just so smart i can learn from
each and one of them so many things i
mean i i don't want to be the smartest
person in the room right it's just
completely boring and and over there i
was okay this this feels just so good um
so this was one thing right the people
and i think that when you look at um you
know a world-class team a game you know
superstars whatever you want to call it
i think that placer has that and it has
that dna so that's a first
um second is the technological challenge
um definitely um at the end of the day
placer was built on technology that was
you know somewhere popular back in 2014
or so and they made a pivot as well um
to do what they do today which is
basically
location analytics for uh for the
physical world
and
the this pivot basically we had no
technology and they didn't have the time
to change it because you know they were
driving on a new business
but there is a scale and there is growth
and we're becoming a serious company so
there is this all these challenges that
you need to basically keep on going with
the with the business but change your
architecture as you go so it's kind of
like replenishing replacing an engine of
a moving car
while driving
and steering right
um so this was so this was the challenge
one of the challenges but the real
challenge with the data you know this is
the data company
and the data is amazing because unlike
most companies that their data is
immutable our data is mutable our py the
points of interest change it means that
we need to go back in history and
recalculate that's something that's
usually never done right you're looking
at five years of historical data and you
need to calculate parts of it and you
need to optimize which part you
calculate
and doing this calculation over and over
again in an optimal and an optimal way
is very difficult and most companies
don't do that to do a rerun of your
entire data and we are talking about a
terabyte and a half of data of daily
ingested data
to do that in most companies no
companies does that at all i don't know
any other company that does that and so
this is one huge major major challenge
on the data side
on the
delivery side is well our report are
completely custom i'm not sure if you
went into into the website and try to
play around of getting understanding
visitation and this whole geospatial
area which is it's very difficult anyway
because it's hard to index
so when we pull out data we pull it in
real time and we do this distributed
computation in real time so we're
sometime pulling in almost at gigabytes
of data doing all these calculations on
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of visitations and pushing it all to the
ui as fast as possible of course all
these aggregations
and so there's also latency issues how
do you pull data from databases do this
calculation in a distributed manner and
pushing them through um to the
presentation layer which is you know
that's another huge challenge so i love
the challenges on both worlds in terms
of the technology on the data side and
on the presentation side
and lastly just in short is the product
market fit is the business
i mean you see we grew so many times um
year over year you know three times year
over year almost four years in a row
it just says it all so you have the
people the technology you have the
product which is amazing and challenging
and the business that drives it through
so you know it's a that's just a
successful company and you see the
people that come in and those are the
people that you know they i think that
they look at placer and they understand
the story and on our growth and they
want to do the same they want to be part
of this success which is just
unbelievable
avi thank you so much for taking this
time and
gain a lot of insight myself as to you
know a little bit of the thinking
process that goes into being an
architect and what i what i love most is
how you're saying you know at the end
everybody everybody should aim to be an
architect and architecture and being an
architect is not just a title it's not
just a leadership by authority but it's
leadership by example and it's requiring
us to
to think deeper about the work that
we're doing and how does it integrate
into the company
as an organization and how does it
integrate into the customer journey and
experience and the product that we're
actually building and how do we build
infrastructure that actually is there to
scale to the point where i can't believe
that ingesting a terabyte and a half of
data in days it's unbelievable hey avi
thank you very very much this was so
enjoyable and thank you very much
stay safe and stealthy bye bye bye thank
you
[Music]